un shooter plus plus plus qui peut aussi
aller péter d énorme dunk candidat au
top 10 de la draft nba 2022 on le passe
à la loupe dans ce podcast le canadien
bénédicte mathurin joueurs en nba pour
arizona son portrait de futurs drafté
c'est en 30 minutes
[Musique]
bénédicte mathurin pour en parler manu
julien uc salue l'équipe talus salut à
tous
bon on rappelle le format on va faire sa
carte d'identité
on passe sept huit minutes là dessus sur
son histoire sur son corps donc ses
capacités physiques et puis sur ses
capacités basket et puis ensuite on va
se poser des questions sur son
intégration en nba son potentiel ce qui
lui faut comme environnement
de manière on va dire optimale pour pour
essayer de grandir et d'atteindre son
fameux plafond mais on commence par se
demander qui est bénédicte mathurin d'où
vient-il ou va-t-il enfin surtout d'où
vient-il et ça c'est manu qui s'en
occupe manu raconte-nous donc payer dick
richard felder mathurin c'est un
jeune joueur qui est né à montréal que
bigard bas ben déjà qui va qui vais tout
finale au soir de la draft donc qu'est
né mon à montréal qu'à deux origines
haïtiennes
car c'est par ses deux parents né à
montréal le 19 juin 2002 donc il va voir
leurs 20 ans le soir de la draft
qu'il a joué plusieurs sports quand ils
étaient jeunes du hockey du foot us et
du basket du coup il a commencé le
basket danse ou lycée donc oui il y joue
quelques quelques années avant de partir
dans l'académie d'amérique latine de la
nba où il jouera deux ans donc ça il a
joué à ces à mexico donc du coup on
parle plusieurs langues français anglais
espagnol et le créole
c'est un joueur qui est fun kenny plus
ou moins une famille de sportifs sa
soeur a joué quatre ans à north carolina
state north carolina state
aujourd'hui elle et elle est assistant
coach dans à bryant oui on universités
aussi
lui a joué lui plus a choisi l'arizona
il a joué deux ans là-bas pour pas mal
de succès sur sa première saison il est
dans l'équipe all freshman dans la
deuxième il élu meilleur joueur de
l'année dans l'actuel meilleur joueur du
tournoi
dans la deuxième dans l'équipe de l'ape
actuelle et dans la seconde équipe de la
saison par par les hippies
il fait une saison à 17 points 5 rebonds
à 37 % aux tirs à trois points et sur
ces deux saisons il est il a 38 à 3
points
et voilà donc maintenant il a il a
déclaré pour pohlad raphia il ya
quelques jours
absolument absolument on enregistre le
19 avril il reste quelques jours avant
la deadline des pré candidature juste
pour expliquer un petit peu le
fonctionnement ensuite les candidats ont
toujours le droit de revenir en nba
temps qu'ils ont embauché un agent
certifié par la nba c'est compliqué hein
et pour les joueurs européens la
deadline elle est enfin européen
internationaux par non la 'deadline' et
est vachement plus lointaines plus
repoussé mais l'enjeu de ces derniers
jours c'est surtout de savoir si celle
d'anne sharp et les jumeaux thompson qui
sont théoriquement éligibles vont se
présenter à la draft cette année puisque
cela chamboulerait un petit peu le top
10 top 10 où pourraient figurer
bénédicte mathurin mais d'abord on parle
de son corps on est à deux mètres 0-1
mais sinon à part ça à quoi il ressemble
huguet on peut dire qu'il a déjà encore
plus tôt mathurin voilà et maintenant
qu'on a fait les meilleurs calembours on
peut se partir c'est plutôt un beau
gosse quand même vous faut le dire parce
qu'une franchise qui qui va aller ouais
on échange physique et mentale physique
une franchise qui va reconstruire la
vouloir mettre une tête d'affiché va
vouloir mettre un gars en avant bas lui
tu peux le mettre en avant plutôt plutôt
charismatique le match sur un mois je
serai pas long soirée avec les quand
j'étais jeune jackson est assez
difficile comme ça j'ai pas tant d'âmes
à turin dans les pattes à côté en termes
de corps basketteur
alors effectivement il est pointé à 2 m
01 on a une petite hésitation n'est pas
sûr qu'il soit aussi grand que ça on va
attendre des mesures un peu officielle
parce que je le vois un peu plus petit 1
m 96 et ça pourrait jouer un petit peu
contre lui à un corps plutôt utilisé
comme on l'a dit plus tôt développé 89
kg et d'envergure mesures est à 2,08
donc 6 9 dans le système américain
en tout cas nord américain ce qui fait
encore intéressant une belle longueur
des masses est grande aussi
un joueur qui a c'est vraiment déjà
tracé on a vu tout le monde a vu les ait
là de mathurin qui monte au panier
athlètes vraiment impressionnant
verticalement une explosivité dans laxe
panier panier correct mais pas non plus
exceptionnel on n'est pas à la hauteur
si on compare à des athlètes des années
précédentes a déjà lenguin armes qui
étaient vraiment des bonnes soeurs sur
le premier pas et c'est dur d'obtenir la
comparaison est évidemment mais pour
être dans le niveau élite in
latéralement c'est pas trop mal moi je
trouve qu'il bouge plutôt bien
mais faut quand même le dire et sa
mâchoire le corps malgré un corps bien
dessinée chez le joueur il ya une âme
manque d'aisance avec vos contacts en
tout cas ils aiment pas trop aller au
contact et c'est assez perturbant convoi
le le phénomène et le gabarit physique
et ça se voit des deux côtés du terrain
donc le corps y est maintenant va
falloir voir le mental et le jeu et je
laisse ça plutôt à mes compères
absolument
qu'est ce qu'on achète donc on a parlé
de son explosivité mais julien si tu
devais vendre bénédicte mathurin à dgm
nba qu'est ce que tu dirais pourquoi ans
le draft ce joueur
mais malgré le corps cas décrit hughes
c'est pas un défenseur quoi je ne
vendrai pas un défenseur en premier lieu
d'ombré d'un square en fait c'est un
gars qui qui sait comment mettre le
ballon dans le panier autant aux shoots
plutôt extérieur que à la finition quand
même près du cercle parce qu'il est je
crois qu'il ya près de 63% au cercle
donc c'est un joueur qui a deux
qui score de 2-2 manière on va dire
proche du panier très proches au cercle
et puis là il a un vrai souci extérieur
qui a qu'il a développés et qu'il a su
faire évoluer donc un scoreur
effectivement un scoreur puisque vous
pouvez aller voir sa fiche pendant qu'on
vous parle
cette saison il est à 17 7 points par
match
est sûre si on si on fait sur du 40
minutes il jouait beaucoup en tout 32
minutes de moyenne mais ça fait ça fait
22 points avec un
shooting de quasiment 58% e f g de plus
de 53% il n'y a pas de signaux négatifs
à ce niveau là il n'y a pas de signal
hyper positif non plus c'est pas un tsa
65 66 comme on peut parfois le voir mais
mais c'est super c'est pas sympa négatif
ça le le ps sait pas trop sans cependant
elle est bien elle est bien elle est
mieux que mathurin
ben mathurin 13e chez dit athlétique
dans le dernier big board de sam wc ni
11e chez kevin o'connor de ringer est
dans le top 100 et veille les bols de
espn qui est fait par hadj alassane
djigo ni et mike schmid ce site l'a
appelé les grands les grands médias
draft il ya d'autres médias spécialisés
qu'on aime bien aussi qui le classe plus
ou moins haut
certains y croient âge et même j'ai même
pas dit combien il était chez envergure
il est 12 donc on on est plutôt dans là
on est plutôt dans la moyenne des
huttes tu te caches mais c'est à toi que
je donne la parole parce que
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi on ne drague
très pas dans le top 8 en fait un score
c'est hyper rare des gars qui savent ce
qu aurait à ce niveau dans une draft en
général les scoreurs c'est c'est rare et
c'est ça de la valeur en nba pourquoi on
dit toujours le top 5 6 s'est formé
après on sait pas trop pourquoi on ne
rentrait pas dans le top 10 quoi
je vais attendre des mecs qui vont
pouvoir créer bon moment surtout sur ce
genre de profil à sa mecque qui a
souvent montré qu'il aimait avoir la
balle en main mais il n'a pas convaincu
là dessus je crois pas dans le créateur
de jeu je crois pas dans le l'initiateur
je crois pas dans le passeur et battu
l'a19 ouais je les jeux les plus bas
est ce qui justifie que j'ai un peu plus
bas je pense c'est déjà ça le fait que
je pense micro pas balle en main et j'ai
un problème je te dis dans la gestion du
contact de physique alors oui une belle
finition près du panier mais qu'ont
souvent il est tout seul la plupart des
paniers qu'il a au cercle c'est des
paniers qui sont avec une passe décisive
dans une équipe très compétitive avec un
excellent spécial gay et beaucoup de
joueurs qui vont jouer en nba je pense
que dans l'équipe ya six mecs là
actuellement juste et année qui pourrait
déjà jouer l'année prochaine en nba
potentiellement et sajoo si la
fourchette large effectivement si c'en
est plutôt ambitieux moi j'aime bien tu
belize l'accord j'aime bien tube ellis
et mais voilà après du côté défensif ya
un manque de
d'application qu'il a tous les outils il
ya des contre-exemples dans les
dernières années on pense forcément
anthony edwards qui était un athlète
peut-être moins puissant que ça et qui
faisait aucun effort en défense qui
allait pas assez près du cercle et qui a
montré des gens deux ans avec les
timberwolves que c'était exceptionnel
mais je suis pas je suis pas encore
convaincu par contre je rassure les gens
j'aime bien des joueurs j'ai pas j'ai
pas personnes entre 0 et 10 mais j'ai
personnes se fout
effectivement mais je te demandais alors
dont tu dis difficile de créer balle en
main le contexte julien qui est notre
spécialiste west coast julien c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on lui demandait
énormément cette année on lui demandait
comme tu disais de mettre la balle dans
le panier
puisqu'il y avait des meneurs qui
s'occupait de créer même des grands
ailiers hughes a mentionné tube ellis
explique nous comment fonctionne un peu
cette équipe d'arizona il ya déjà il y
avait deux meneurs en fait qui devrait
monard
qui vous est pas ensemble forcément mais
qui se relaient il ya un quart chris
acquis un
soupetard téléthon
je souhaitais en est-on estoniens
l'estonien ça ne trompe à chaque fois
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris le temps
mais je me suis encore trompé estoniens
qui a mais vrai meneur de jeu et
acquiert en pétard
un gars qui arrivait cette année un
réseau n'a
et puis effectivement il ya du baby ski
premier qui est un joueur assez
polyvalent en attaque capable de trouver
qu'un plan sabonis si on devrait voir la
savoie et nice le savent donné son gala
enfin de sacramento c'est ça tu veux
dire le fils
sa venue ignore ouais ouais et donc
effectivement on dit on ne mettait pas
eu le ballon dans la main forcément pour
créer april a fait moi je vous dis tout
de suite tu gardes il l'a fait moi je
trouve pas mal durant l'année de mieux
en mieux ça que c'est comme un passeur
précis je vois quand si quand il décide
de faire des passes et des pâtes précise
si si si et il fait des passes de
différentes manières
voilà mais c'était pas si le profil
calque 66 c'est intéressant parce qu'il
a 14 % d'assists mais sur les matches
face à des adversaires top 50
donc il en a joué quand même
quelques-uns selon ken pomme il est à
19% à 6 donc c'est à dire que plus le
niveau augmente est plus il était
peut-être amenés à passer la balle parce
qu'il allait pas au cercle et plus il y
arrivait avec un taux de balle perdue
qui lui reste elle même donc ça c'est un
signe positif par rapport à ça il faut
le noter dans son du tube voilà et dans
tout l'est dans tous les alors je trouve
dans tous les compartiments du jeu quand
là quand la presse aux mortiers des
présents il est présent au shoot il est
présent à la création et on va reparler
peut-être il est présent aussi en
défense comme s'il faut moi je pense que
c'est le joueur qu'il faut challenge est
pas sage vouloir 46 mg et le fait c'est
pour ça que je me dis que une fois qu'il
sera pro
la 6e pas chinese et sera the rich
adéquat oui bah presse le mieux c'est un
joueur qui s'auto challenge mais
certains ont besoin d'un petit coup de
boost mais effectivement le profil
psychologique idéal c'est le joueur qui
va travailler tout seul
il avait un autre rôle hugues et manu
avec avec team canada qui les canadiens
il avait un rôle où il crée y crée il
était amené à créer un petit peu plus
puisque lille n'avait pas ce kerkri ça à
côté de lui même s'il ya des créateurs
team canada il ya les nems rare d'y
aller ces joueurs là mais mais dans son
équipe s'il était amené à avoir le
ballon hugues est ce que tu as des
souvenirs de
de ce championnat u19 ouais ouais ouais
je me refais ya pas très longtemps là
pour mon plus grand plaisir
effectivement il y avait amené en est
mardi qui est assez bon créateur il joue
avec caleb joss stone qui essaie d'avoir
le ballon mais c'était pas ouf lui il
avait la balle en main pour le coup et
c'était pas terrible honnêtement c'était
pas c'était pas c'était pas incroyable
c'est alors effectivement je rejoins
julien c'est un très bon passeur dans
laxe panier panier c'est à dire que je
sors un petit tiendront effectivement il
peut trombi peut trouver passe au sol
qui passe à une main passe au sol passe
directe passe lobée ils maîtrisent un il
le faisait déjà avec zaki team canada le
pivot gens qui jouent à tour du jour là
cette année il peut passer à une main en
feintant un flotteur nokia de la parité
dans la passif un flotteur qui maîtrise
très bien au niveau de sa main droite et
il peut trouver finalement une passe par
deux succès terra donc oui il ya de la
variété
mais il faut pas pas de variété
française évidemment mais fut désolé je
suis désolé fin de journée c'est bien
c'est bien moi j'aime bien déroulée
je me lâche
par contre au niveau du du drive envoyé
de jax été assez limitées dans les
drives il était très uniforme n'y avait
pas de changement de direction je
trouvais ya pas vraiment de changement
de vitesse décéléré au niveau du contact
donc voilà c'est là que j'ai eu un
premier flag j'ai voulu y croire j'étais
très amoureuse bénédicte mathurin et et
à chaque fois je me dis raf il a quand
même à défaut et je n'arrive pas y
croire en ballon mort tu désolé bali me
mets mais ben et de notre équipe est là
pour ça et aller sur le site il vous
donnera plein d'arguments bien plus
positivement si effectivement ben mais
il a peut-être ce côté un petit peu
alors que j'ai pas en comment on dit
c'est pas cocorico pour les canadiens
mais
mais c'est un peu on va dire fier
d'aider ce joueur qui vient de la même
ville que lui puisque mature ans vient
de montréal on l'a dit au début ma nul
c'est quelque chose que ouais je sais
que c'est quelque chose que tu regarde
beaucoup la capacité de faire des passes
etc
laisse moi regarder rapidement ou est-ce
que tu as bénédicte mathurin tu là
exactement comme moi à la 15e position
donc pas dans le top 10 non plus tu y
crois tu y crois aux tuiles crois pas
moi j'y crois je propose le fou du roi
par la défense et je crois par
l'initiation
après il ya eu du pot il ya en fait je
suis jusmy surplus sur le potentiel que
sur ce que j'ai vu bois sur toile à
passer à la défense parce que de la
défense il ya deux il ya des coutumes
des beautés joli trou d'air des fois
mais quand il est concentré lilas c'est
bon j'ai juste une interrogation c'est
ce qui va pouvoir défendre sur plusieurs
positions
vu la taille l'envergure c'est ce qu'il
va pouvoir faire rien que 1 2 je suis
pas sûre et 1 2 3 je suis encore
beaucoup moins sûre il faudra lui
trouver le rôle défensif en fait qui lui
qui lui convient pour quoi qu'il soit
1.1 point noir de le de son équipe qui
soit pas trop ciblée qui soit pas trop
ce genre de choses en défense
inter sans julien et il défend dès
qu'elle le profil cette année mathurin
valide voilà saïda fondée soit des
petits dédiés sont des arriérés sont des
meneurs et
n'importe quel était cachée après il est
pas négatif en défense étaient séparés
c'est quand même une défense qui est
très agressive et il était dans le ton
n'était dans le temps de la défense
et quand il fallait tenir des d un
contre un il détient mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des îles à montils avait montré
sa hotte 19 il a des trouvères
extraordinaire mais sa fiche
complètement pas ça n'intéresse pas là
un certain moment alors après arizona
c'est pas la même chose parce que je
pense que là il ya eu vraiment un gros
effort sur la défense au niveau
collectif et
voilà après ça n'empêche pas de parfois
se déconcentrer totalement mais après
bon il fait des rotations il fait des
il sait faire quoi c'est des choses qui
sait faire c'est pas un problème de
compréhension de la défense collective
ou de saint prime de motivation et de
concentration tu trouves pas que dès
qu'il ya un écran c'est vraiment là en
fait ils disparaître tout le temps c'est
qu'il effectue à l époque focus mais dès
qu'il ya un écran qu'il faut traverser
un écran mais c'est à dire à un nom du
contact japon en vie et ils s'arrêtent
nos qui demande un switch facilement moi
j'ai vraiment cette impression là que
dès que tu appelles pick and roll la
pâture en effet on bat les gars demain
et c'est très très souvent il ya plein
d'outils pour défendre il peut vraiment
s'y mettre et est stoppé des gars comme
et de brad 2 et ya pas très longtemps
avec georgia où c'était vraiment sur
courant alternatif et c'est hyper
frustrant vraiment vraiment frustrant sa
tenue lors du contact c'est vraiment
n'ont envie de se faire mal ouais mais
est-ce que du coup pendant sur des
switch est ce que vous avez des
souvenirs que parce que quand tu switch
après tu te retrouves sur le gros est ce
que
est ce qu'il est ce qui est ce qu'il se
bat est-ce qu'ils empêchent les recrues
passe est-ce qu'il a la puissance sur le
bas du corps pour pouvoir un petit peu
contesté le gars qui l'enfoncent passer
devant on a dit qu'il a une envergure
correct comment ça se passait au niveau
de ces switchs
moi j'ai pas de souvenirs donc c'est
peut-être un peu inquiétant
et même pas
je ne suis même pas de moment où il
défend des gros
contenants ça qui fait des écrans retard
sur des gros il ya des boxeurs et c'est
donc il accepte quand même con qu'on lui
monte dessus derrière et cauet qui
tienne et comme il a un koloko et intubé
liste oui en toute amitié évidemment
toute amitié dans les respects direct du
basket comme il a un koloko un tube élit
son second cadeau surtout un colloque
hausse à aider vraiment beaucoup
là dessus mais il a pu fois ci la
puissance en bas du corps pour pouvoir
encaisser un peu plus grand que lui un
peu plus fort que lui
manu c'est quoi le contexte idéal pour
pour lui dans ses premières années en
nba avec quelle on va le faire jouer
deux probablement
avec quelle
avec quels joueurs à côté de lui et ce
qu'il faut et ce qu'il faut un joueur
qui va plus être dans le dans le slash
est ce qu'il faut un meneur un peu plus
organisateur même si ça existe de moins
en moins est ce qu'il lui faut des
shooteurs s quel genre de profil qu'elle
quel genre de rôle il lui faut moi je le
vois bien en spots of shooter sur les
premières les premiers matches et
premiers mois pour les premières années
donc avec une équipe qui a une bonne
vision de jeu de façon générale comme
les dents avec arizona où tout le monde
pouvait passer c'était assez assez top
avant d'avoir et pour lui c'était dans
le meilleur contexte parce que tout le
monde pouvait aller à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur mais c'était surtout les
gros qui alec tube lycées ekoloko moi je
le vois vraiment plus ou moins le même
système comme ça un futur vraiment au
début à l'extérieur et après s'il peut
aller anna avec le spacing nba je pense
que ça va l'aider à aller un peu plus au
cercle mais un peu plus tard l'âge
vraiment pour gagner dix minutes je le
vois plus dans un rôle de de spotters
twitter comme ça
intéressant donc toi tu le vois pas
forcément titulaire dès le début de sa
carrière
bah ça dépend l'équipe qui le choisira
mais moi je le vois au début en tout cas
je le vois plus en ce dans une seconde
unit way cette deuxième option d'une
seconde unit
ok ok intéressant
si je te laisse le temps d'y réfléchir
mais si tu as des exemples de joueurs
qui ont qui sont un peu dans ce rôle là
aujourd'hui pendant ce temps hugues
mêmes questions sur le le schéma un peu
idéale qui pourrait y avoir autour de
lui en termes de pas vraiment de
position mais vraiment de ce qu'ils
soient quelconque besoin de savoir faire
les gens qui l'entourent
moi j'aimerais bien avoir avec
effectivement il y en a très peu mais un
vrai bon meneur j'aimerais bien
quelqu'un qui lui aussi un partenaire
qui acceptent de jouer sans ballon parce
que je pense qu'il faut quand même pour
les cd balle en main à bénédicte mathieu
race ne fera aucun effort de l'autre
côté du terrain et il faut développer
son potentiel
il avait quand même un contexte où le
tout le monde l'a dit parfait arizona
donc à un big qui peut rouler à
l'extérieur qui peut porter la balle
peut-être du coup une équipe qui a pas
ça vu la position à laquelle il est
prévu pour l'instant
mais voilà j'aimerai bien un jeu un peu
organisés sur lequel il peut prendre des
coups de feu qu'on a très peu dit c'est
qu'on a pas là d'un excellent tireur
mais c'est pas juste un mec en catch and
shoot ça mec qui peut vraiment créé son
propre tir qui déclenché de très loin
qui est très bon soit sur du mobile ou
chauffe en chaîne et je réceptionne et
je déclenche alors je le fais à la
caméra saraya n'a pas la vidéo et je
fais très mal en plus mais il peut aussi
en sortie d'écran très bon dans les
systèmes de ce type floppy renversement
et se retourner et est renvoyé et avec
un dribble de dribbles pouvoir se créer
un petit écart aussi est déclenché et
donc pour le coup il peut exister dans
n'importe quel contexte de tir
au niveau supérieur ça c'est intéressant
c'est pas que un joueur de spots up en
tout cas potentiellement c'est un joueur
qui va
être à l'aise dans un jeu de mouvement
loin du ballon et être une menace pour
la défense aussi
est ce qu'un mec comme ça fait trop tôt
pour les comparaisons mais on demandait
un contexte et manu voiliers du sortie
de banc est ce qu'un mec comme tiger
heroes c'est pas un contexte parfait
pour pour bénédicte mathurin
pour ceux qui pensaient à l'heure
où pareille on
ne pas en comparaison sur le joueur mais
en comparaison de rôle plutôt de rôle
que tu lui imaginé avoir que tu
l'imaginés avoir parlé ouais ça c'est
pas mal mais qu elle c'est pas mal
j'aime l'idée en tout cas
tyler héros c'est pas mal d'autant que
c'est dans une équipe qui fonctionne
bien et avec des gens durs autour après
les têtes dans le staff et le biais quoi
si
way avec toronto ouais c'est le tome 2
julien
est ce que tu peux me parler un petit
peu de sa capacité à conduire le ballon
à son randle
tu l'as vu jouer des pick and roll donc
tu l'as dit il est capable de faire des
passes hugues l'a dit aussi mais est ce
qu'il est capable de varier le rythme le
le la direction de d'utiliser en fait
ses capacités athlétiques à grâce aux
dribbles
moi je pense qu'il va être forte dans
les clauses hawks où il faut exploser
direct sur six à neuf c'est moi je
trouve que c'est un très bon joueur de
catch and shoot dimanche il a la preuve
il a évolué comme dans tout il était
presque 100% de ces trois points qui
était assisté l'année dernière et cette
année ses 75 % donc ça veut dire qu'il
fait évoluer son truc mais surtout sur
les sur l'éclat aux autres c'est simple
parce que il faut exploser fois les tout
droit il faut aller le plus vite
possible au cercle ça il sait faire mais
son dribble pour l'instant c'est le truc
auxquelles je crois le moins
offensivement et c'est ce qui le freine
complètement dans la création il avait
un sens
est-ce que tu comment tu peux expliquer
ça il s'est juste un manque de technique
où je sais que les joueurs qui ont un
centre de gravité assez aussi ils ont
plus de mal à dribbler bas c'est logique
et donc du coup ils sont parfois gêné je
trouve pas qu'il en soit je trouve qu'il
ya un centre de gravité très non non non
non non non non je n'aime pas mais le
juge urgent besoin de points mais
deux techniques je vois plutôt ça comme
ça de dabo alors c'est de l'habitude de
faire de jouer ce rôle il était donc
seul handicap vachement sur la création
quoi que ce soit ou 19 mai - arizona sur
ces coups là quand ça va tout droit ça
va et c'est assez c'est assez troublant
parfois quand on va de metz d'arizona ya
du belize qui est capable de remonter le
terrain de justement de faire des fans
de regard ou de corps
d finir en lay up et puis beaucoup
d'après tu as battu rennes qui est dans
la même position
qu'il souffre de dents sur les
défenseurs en finissant
un petit peu bizarrement quoi donc c'est
pas je pense que c'est un problème
technique donc ça je sais pas si ça se
travaille à ce niveau là je pense que ça
se travaille se doit s'améliorer mais
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment un
truc sur lequel il faut qu'il bosse fois
ci s'il tombe dans un staff qui veut te
faire jouer plus dans la création ça va
être un axe de travail assez fort ouais
oui c'est ça est-ce que vous avez des
comparaisons plancher c'est à dire
niveau minimum il va faire une carrière
je pas de 4 6 ans et il aura ce rôle là
et plafonds
moi j'en ai une du plafond que je vous
soumets immédiatement puisque c'est un
joueur avec le profil statistique à peu
près similaire un petit peu plus petits
au profil statistique en acier
évidemment
on n'était pas sûr qui shoote alors que
la mâture et on est sûr
il provoquait peu de lancers francs il
allait alors que mathurin ça vaille la
36e
donc c'est pas mal mais il était dans un
collectif - huile etc arizona ces deux
nouvelles mitchell
en fait ces deux communes truc auquel je
pense et moi mais
ce qu'est ce qu'il va plus au cercle kim
avait freiné c'était la capitale et
auxerre qui était plus forte tu vois par
rapport à du nobel j'ai l'impression en
écoute sur l'année
il tant il fait 116 klaus tout pour
pour donovan mitchell sur son année
sophomore à louisville et battu rang en
temps 274 donc ils tentent plus de tirs
au cercle et en plus il provoque plus de
lancers francs aussi
manu oui pas sur mitchell mais sur des
comparaisons
moi il m'a j'avais en tête danny green
je vais regarder le danny green de north
carolina
carrés à peu près la même le même rôle
en fait de shooter qui défendent un peu
pas un peu partout calé au cercle tapait
des taux marque j'avais pas se souvenir
de danny green mais est ce un mal quand
j'ai regardé les vidéos me tiens il ya
un truc là dedans et dans le
dans l'évolution possible selon le
contexte nba je trouve que ça lui
correspond bien aussi de voilà de ce
sera peut-être le brider un peu bleuets
de et gâché un peu son talent d'enfer
que un twitter mais j'aime bien le le ce
rôle là en fait ce type de joueur rôle
là qu'il avait notamment aux spurs dans
la grande époque
très intéressant c'est très surprenant
comme comparaison hughes
l'idéal c'est claude ribbe se
développent et du coup je vais je rester
sourd à mais comme style très haut
niveau
dans le profil peut-être plus déjà épais
physiquement métal et aux dribbles et
mieux et si ça marche pas et on va
espérer que ça marche mais ça marche pas
je vais aller chanter d'un profil sous
il dit
al-agha whitson junior et je vais
rejoindre peut-être manu dans le dans le
profil amant qui finit spécialiste rien
dix derrière et ça fait un peu gâchis
mais ça scénario qui est possible
oui oui oui et s'ils développent le
dribble il ya aussi un petit côté
peut-être kevin carter j'ai pensé aussi
mais s'ils développent le dribble il
souffre tellement de choses parce que
nous y en a certes devient sa de ça on
parle pas du tout du même genre ont bon
on est entrain role players peut-être
plafond titulaire sans le dribble et
seaal dribble on peut parler d'un mec
qui peut devenir tête all star et on
peut s'ouvrir des joueurs comme des
teams and evil booker qui était plus
dans le déjà fait 7 etc mais qui a pu se
créer beaucoup plus au fur et à mesure
et qui au départ était utilisé trop en
sortie tout je suis d'accord c'est le
swing skill donc bénédicte mathurin pour
l'instant entre 10 et 14 moi je pense
que je vais le monte personnellement
dans mon prochain board parce que je
pense que le potentiel en vaut la peine
et que le dribble c'est pas quelque
chose de si compliqué à développer que
cela
même si tu grimace
est-ce que vous avez des choses à
ajouter ou est-ce que ah oui comment
comment on voit par rapport aux gens de
sa position aux joueurs de sa position
pardon qui sont en gros johnny davis
il n'a pas tellement des arrières au
tchad badji
même si plus de 3
[Musique]
et puis voilà quoi celle de sharp
bryce mcgowan il est plutôt il est
plutôt dans la fourchette haute des
arrières comme
ils sont tous très différents quoi
donner de délai il posté de partout en
fait ça ne fait pas forcément
mature pour l'instant mais mon avec
moins d'efficacité que mathieu c'est pas
le même collectif au tourisme pour pro
pour provoquer et on va enfin côté pas
ouvert mais moi j'aime bien savoir
qu'est ce qui différencie outre est
l'âge comme ça hein bénédicte naturel
pour les gens d'un quai les blu vivenzi
houda johnny jogging alors plus calé
bluff parce que je trouve qu'il est
alors que les bleus étaient un peu plus
petit et encore sa régularité
ouais mais sur quoi parce que je
laquelle est bloqué la fine les landes
saison vous tirez les deux sont des
mauvais finisseur panier les deux sont
pas forcément des très bons créateur
balle aux mains des passeurs les deux
sont des défenseurs potentiel et voilà
hélas un qui est considéré vraiment
second tour et l'autre qui me parfois
top d'ici bas april ya une différence de
contexte ne peut pas dire que calais
blog soit dans un mauvais contexte
et calais bluffe tout à moins de 50% au
cercle alors que bénédicte mathurin 64%
alors même si je suis d'accord avec toi
sur certains contacts ça explose il ya
parfois où il est tellement au dessus
physiquement de l'adversaire que c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il a pas besoin de
d'aller chercher ce contact donc pour
moi la différence elle est là comme la
capacité athlétique est pas tout à fait
le pop comme moi j'ai l'impression aussi
que mature il n'a pas besoin de trop
tant que ça la balle dans la main il a
25 % de taux d'usagé tu vois c'est ya
des matches on en parlé avec lui il ya
des matches où on se rend pas compte en
fait il a collé plus 20 points et c'est
pas pareil que moi quelque chose qu'on
va remarquer quoi c'est vraiment
c'est un scoreur quoi vraiment dans ce
que
il à dallas il ya une chance qui devient
d'un gros ce copain qui doit un score
correct et n'oubliez pas ce qui est
assez rare les scoreurs qu'on pas trop
besoin d'eux long aujourd'hui on va
penser à claix thompson alors évidemment
on va pas faire des comparaisons qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être mais mais c'est
assez rare les secours savourer le
meilleur plafond pause c'étaient les
outils physique parce qu'ils aient les
outils physique
l'idéal le truc de ouf et etc tacler
thompson à la fin qui posent peu de
dribbles qui peut défendre plein de
positions quand même assez athlétique et
qui shoote à un volume énorme de toutes
les positions ce serait
le champ des possibles est énorme
si vous avez quelque chose d'autre à
ajouter allez-y sinon je vous pose la
fameuse désormais fameuse question bonus
moi je regarde juste sur tout ce qu'a
dit hugo tout débuts sur le l'attaquent
du cercle j'ai réécouté un podcast qui
la donne qui l'avait fait il ya un an et
demi avec un une chaîne de télé
canadienne où il disait son rôle dans
high school c'est justement de faire que
ça que d'attaquer le cercle donc il a
dit moi finalement j'ai pas peur c'est
après que ça a évolué dans son jeu mais
mon rôle dans high school s'était
attaqué le cercle et provoquer des
fautes donc je pense finalement ça il
l'a toujours eue ans en lui et il l'aura
toujours c'est vraiment après le
contexte academy nba qui lui a permis de
faire autre chose où il disait là il a
plus développé son jeu parce qu'il avait
plus d'entraînements arizona c'est
pareil plus entraînement donc il a
vraiment calibré sur son sursaut shoot
et je pense que ça finalement il l'a
toujours en lui l' attaque du cercle
eric selon le rôle il va pouvoir y aller
que quoi qu'il arrive ça se perd pas ce
truc là
intéressant et j'ajoute que si il a le
but qu'il est passé par les académies
nba le track-record c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est vachement valorisé
par les front office et le fait qu'ils
soient connus depuis très longtemps
qu'ils soient passés par un cheminement
très où il est facile d'avoir des
retours sur son comportement sur sur ce
qu'il a fait et sait s'il est drafté au
ça veut dire qu'il ya aucun problème
comportemental et qu' il a il a coché
toutes les bonnes cases depuis le moment
où il très à l'académie
amérique latine tu as dit
manu
ben mathurin donc c'était son podcast
avoir part qu'il sera drafté mais vous
avez à peu près les enjeux de ce joueur
maintenant vient la question bonus
puisqu'il s'appelle alors j'aurais pu
faire une question sur le québec mais
j'ai préféré une question culinaire
parce que vous connaissez je suis un
gourmand et donc on va parler d eux
puisqu'on est avec bénédicte et donc ma
question que je vous ai envoyé est ce
que vous préférez les oeufs bénédicte
les oeufs mimosa les oeufs cocotte ou
les oeufs à la diable à la diable c'est
avec mayo et moutarde qu'on mélange avec
les oeufs avec les jaunes et qu'on met à
la place du jeune après ça fait
tellement questions pour un champion tu
sais quelle est la recette était le
mimosa le diable
qui veut commencer qui veut commencer
moi je préfère les oeufs cocotte
maintenant c'est sur ces mots c'est mon
enfance
alors alors pourquoi qu'est ce que tu
aimes dans l'oeuf cocotte est ce qu'on
peut développer à monique
presque six ans et moi c'est vraiment
les oeufs cocotte pour le côté souvenir
ok
exactement
trading je sais que tu cuisines alors je
sais pas si tu les maîtrisent les la
cuisson des e mails et j'ai un oeuf
mollet mon gars exceptionnel d'accord
trop fier de moi non la flèche de
bénédicte cfec des dépôts chez
eux c'est pas facile non la fatigue je
prends le jeu prend la famille mozart
c'est évident et c'est je dis tu mets
delà du persil de la ciboulette fraîche
la petite mayonnaise d olive a tranché
c'est honteux c'est honteux a cependant
reçu deux d'accord
allez maïté a choisi les les mimosas
manu pareil
aïe aïe aïe tu as les oeufs bénédictine
alors que mc je pensais les plus
sophistiquées mais sont peut-être trop
sophistiqué c'est plus un truc de brunch
de bobos les bénéfices pour se rattraper
mais de la bénédicte h sur les au mimosa
si tu veux c'est tout ce qu'on peut
faire c'est vrai aussi bon égalité entre
love cocotte et l'oeuf mimosas on vous
laissera trancher sur les réseaux
sociaux c'était donc
un podcast sur les os bénédicte mathurin
le canadien le québécois candidats à la
draft
peut-être qu'il va être le quai le
québécois le plus au draft et non c'est
parce que le guen sorte il a été drafté
bas
lac est drafté mais bon c'est bien fort
possible pardon il a été drafté où les
signatures du temple games ouais je sais
plus
c'est possible bon en tout cas bénédicte
mathurin ce sauf surprise sera drafté
top 20 on vous laisse aller voir sa
fiche son scouting report c'est scouting
report sur sur envergure point ces eaux
et et on vous invite à partager le
contenu est allé explorer ce site où
yann aux vidéos nos podcasts nos
articles notre big board ya tout
abonnez-vous à youtube abonnez vous à 20
de nos podcasts abonnez-vous à switch et
abonnez-vous à twitter aussi instagram
tout ça bref une draft et de merci mon
cher julien rodriguez donc ce ne sera
pas difficile de faire mieux
bisous les gars merci beaucoup à bientôt
pour plus de contenu draft ciao ciao bye
salut à tous